what elements make up a great story
well i think when you're when you're
writing and you sort of have an idea and
you go wow will this actually make a
great feature film or not
um i usually think about okay are these
three elements part of the idea or could
i find a way to sort of embed these
three elements
and one is that it needs to have a main
character
who wants something really badly
and
the second one is it has to promise lots
of conflict like when we
imagine the story and we imagine what
the character wants and what they're
going to have to do to get it we already
start to kind of imagine all the crazy
obstacles that that person's going to
have to face in order to get what they
want and then we get really interested
right and then third i think a way to
tell if your um
idea will make a great movie is
um does it have human emotions in it
that we can relate to you know even if
you're writing about science fiction or
you're writing a horror movie or
something set way in the past where you
really have no
um immediate connection to the time or
place or characters there have to be
those human feelings and desires and
fears that we can relate to you know so
i always think those are the three
criteria that make a great movie or tv
idea um and obviously if you're writing
a tv show you know the idea has to
promise lots of story you know when
you're writing a feature it's a
contained three-act structure right so
it has it's it's a contained story with
an end
so um you know thinking about that idea
all those elements still have to be at
play and then in addition when you're
writing a tv limited series or a tv
show with multiple seasons you know how
are
all those characters and all those
conflicts going to spool out and promise
lots of conflict to come
yeah
great great three tips
first off
how would we know that the characters
want is really strong enough that it
warrants
us being invested in them right
well
as a story consultant i mean i work with
a lot of screenwriters i work with
professional screenwriters who are
working in the industry and i also work
with beginning people and people who are
kind of in the middle of their
journey toward being a professional
screenwriter
but even with the professional
screenwriters that i work with it's
always the same it's like
every time i read the script it's like
what do they want
and
the writer looks at me like
i have no idea like they've written a
whole script and they're just they still
kind of don't understand
what the main character wants and so
when someone is thinking about their
their main character you know i always
like to break down what they want into
two parts like they have an emotional
need
like to find love or connection or for
revenge or power or whatever and then
there's a specific immediate goal that
they pursue in the story that satisfies
that emotional need
so
if you don't have those two things and
know them pretty clearly
you're probably going to write a lot of
pages that you don't end up having in
your final version of the script because
you know i don't i don't know about you
but i've written full scripts where i
literally have no idea what they want
and this happens this happens this
happens and then i look at the script
and i'm like what is this like what is
this thing why should i be invested in
watching this story
so i think a way to know
if you if your character has enough of
an engine to drive a feature or a
television show it's like they have to
have a very specific emotional need
and then they have a very specific goal
that they're pursuing in the story to
satisfy that need now when they start
the movie or the tv show that immediate
goal that they're pursuing could be like
the wrong thing
right
and their goal changes
but usually the emotional need stays
constant as they sort of grow then they
may change that that immediate goal to
kind of
reveal their their growth as a character
or whatever but like you know do you
know
what your character emotionally needs
and wants and then what is it that they
specifically decide to do
to satisfy that need and once you have
that lined up then you're good you're
good to go and start writing
with conflict
how do we know
how much house like is it too much too
soon or there can never be too much
conflict too soon like you know some
people think they have conflict in their
story and it's actually not it's it's
too it's too meek it's not it's not
enough right that's a great question
about conflict um
for me
like even if you're writing the most
small specific character-driven
movie that takes place in a very kind of
um
small location with just a few
characters
there has to be
lots of conflict there needs to be
internal conflict and external conflict
of some kind however that doesn't mean
your your movie has to start with like
conflict conflict conflict conflict too
much conflict because
after a while it's like whoa what is
this what's happening here what's this
about so um one way
to sort of um think about conflict and
how it works especially when you're when
you're writing a feature film is that
you know at the beginning of the story
your character may want something
that they don't have
right and they're just kind of living
their life but we get the sense that
they want something that they don't have
and then there is this inciting incident
or call to adventure where
maybe they have the chance
to get what they want but it's like
super scary right like there's something
emotionally dangerous about that call or
physically dangerous and so they go nope
i'm going to refuse that call because
i'm too afraid and then something
usually happens to kind of force the
person
to take action and heed the call to
adventure and go on the journey at the
end of act one so it's not like you have
to have conflict conflict you know it's
like like
usually most really great stories um
depending on what genre you're writing
in i mean if you're writing an action
movie there should be something big up
top right and then it creates a question
we're like what happened and then we
slow down and we start to go meet up
with the character and what they're
trying to figure out
um so you can have sections of your
script that are quiet where we're just
kind of revealing character and they're
still trying to get what they want but
the conflicts are smaller and more
internal
um
but in the climax of your movie whether
you're writing a tiny movie or you're
writing a huge movie you know where
there's car chases and explosions or
whatever
that is the moment where there has to be
big conflict either emotionally or
physically
so conflict is something
that um you have to kind of modulate
throughout the script right and um there
are moments in the story that are
quieter where maybe we get in act two we
have a moment where everything kind of
slows down and we have a scene with two
characters connecting on a deeper
emotional level that then create bigger
stakes so that when they move into the
next section of conflict the stakes are
even higher just because we had this
really
tiny quiet little scene that had no
conflict in it
so each scene has to move the story
forward and conflict will kind of ebb
and flow
but there always has to be tension in
the story and
um
the reason for that is that you know
every every movie every tv show every
story creates a dramatic question
you know and the dramatic question is
will the person get what they want or
not and that's what holds us to the
story and so if somebody has a goal and
they go after it
and they get it
we're like
okay the story's over like you know um
but if they want something
and it's really hard either emotionally
or physically
we're gonna keep watching because if we
are if we have empathy toward that
character and we understand what they
want and why
we generally want them to get it and so
we're with them and that question of
will they get it or will they not get it
is what holds us to the story and in
order for us for that question to kind
of be
dramatic and suspenseful we need
conflict
yeah
and so what if the character gets what
they want early in the film
but it turns out that
didn't really fulfill their desired need
and we as the viewer go on this journey
to see them get it and we want to root
for them and think oh wow they have it
but then it turns out to be either a
disappointment or um you know traumatic
to their lives and so then
we follow the rest of the film of them
trying to sort out
this this goal
right so
so yeah
like that that happens a lot in
storytelling right where the character
remember when i was talking about that
idea that they that they have this
emotional need and then they have the
specific goal and they pursue the wrong
goal like for example let's just take um
a rom a teen rom-com just because that's
an easy genre to talk about so
so
a trope in rom-coms especially in the
teen sort of world is that
that let's say we have a female
character and she loves the wrong boy
she loves kevin
kevin is the popular boy kevin has the
swoopy hair kevin has the letterman's
jacket right
and um she wants kevin so bad and we the
audience are going
actually
it's joe the nerdy guy that's for you
but but she has to figure it out herself
so let's say she gets together with
kevin
and and she's with kevin and
she's starting to realize like oh
this isn't really good like i don't
really like like him or i don't really
like being part of this
this this crowd or whatever you know
she's starting to realize who she really
loves
which is joe but like she rejected joe
way back there
so now joe is with sally
and now
she has to try to get joe back like it
becomes it because it can become part of
you creating an arc for your main
character and they sort of get a deeper
understanding of what it is they really
want
you know that's related to their
emotional need for love and connection i
don't know if that answered your
question yeah it does it does and i'm
sorry the third part was are there
enough emotions do we feel empathetic
toward the character yeah okay so so
do we so creating empathy i mean for
those of your um your viewers who are
writing you know we all know that the
one thing we really need to create
between the audience and the main
character is empathy and empathy um
to me empathy is sharing the feelings
and understanding why someone's doing
something and recognizing those motives
as human
in yourself
so even if you have an antagonist who's
like doing despicable disgusting
horrible things if we know why that
person is doing it they feel like a real
person
right and they're humanized and they
don't feel stereotypical or villainy you
know like twirling their mustaches
um and with a main character empathy is
is really important too because
again if we're sharing the emotions of
our main character main character in the
story they're actually the window
through which we're experiencing the
journey
so you know the the function of the hero
in storytelling is for the reader or the
audience to actually be in that person
situation and experience that journey
through their eyes and so in order to do
that we have to feel a connection
to that person
so um a lot of times you know students
or writers ask me like i want to write
an anti-hero like my my main character
is not likeable i don't care they're not
gonna be likable and i'm like great
they don't have to be likable but they
do have to be empathetic in other words
we have to understand their motives why
they're doing what they're doing
and so most main characters are likeable
you know like we we like them and we
want them to get what they want but
there are some main characters um
like in the talented mr ripley i don't
know if you've seen that movie but um
tom ripley is does terrible things and i
don't want to do spoiler i think
everybody needs to watch this movie it's
one of my favorite movies especially if
you want to have a main character who
who does bad things but we're still
connected to him and we're still
watching him going
don't do it tom you know it's just like
don't but we know what he wants because
it's set up so clearly at the beginning
that we feel for him and we understand
him and we are riveted by his journey
because as he does one terrible thing
after another we keep wanting him to
have a chance to take it all back and to
make the right choice and so even though
he's an anti-hero we're like please
don't do anything bad please make choose
the person who loves you
he didn't choose you know it's just it's
a brilliant movie because we
we hate the guy but we have complete
empathy
for that person and you know if we're
connected to the character that way we
will follow that person to the end of
the movie or the end of the tv show
because
we're interested we
and we care and we understand why
they're doing what they do